I can't explain why,
but every time December rolls around I start craving pavlovas.
Baked them multiple times all throughout the month,
but today it's my first.
I start by whipping my egg whites until soft peaks form
before gradually adding in my sugar.
Once that all looks glossy,
I add in my vanilla paste and let that go for another minute.
This point I add in my cream of tartar and some cornstarch
before folding that all in
and transferring that over to a baking sheet.
Make sure there's a good dip in the middle,
and then put it in the oven at 3:50,
but then immediately turn the heat down to 200.
Let that bake for about an hour and a half
while I get started on my cherry compote.
While that's reducing,
I make a quick whipped cream by combining some heavy cream,
vanilla, and powdered sugar.
Once that's all ready to go,
I take out my cooled pavlova,
spread the heavy cream on top and the cherry compote as well.
I love a good orange zest in my cherry compote.
Garnish it with some Rosemary and there we go!